ايام قليله فقط كانت تفصل عباس خان عن
رؤيه اولاده بعد سجنه لمده 13 شهرا في
دمشق ولكن عندما ذهبت والدته لزيارته
الاثنين الماضي قيل لها انه مات الحكومه
السوريه افادت في وقت لاحق بان خان وجد
منتحرا في زنزانته وقد شنق نفسه الامر
الذي اعتبره شقيقه اهانه كامله كل
المؤشرات كانت تدل على انهم يجهزونه
للرحيل الى بريطانيا وفجاه يقوم بطريقه
غامضه بشنق نفسه هذا الامر غير منطقي وتصر
الحكومه السوريه على ان تشريح جثته قد
اظهر انه مات شنقا وعرضت على عائلته ارسال
اطبائ الخاصين للتحقق من سبب الوفاه ولكن
العائله رفضت الفكره يعلمون جيدا انه لا
يوجد اي طبيب بريطاني قد يوافق على السفر
الى بلد غريب لتشريح جثه
غريبه عرضت علينا عائلته هذه الرساله
المكتوبه بيد الدكتور خان فقد كتب لابنته
يوم الرابع من ديسمبر كانون الاول سوف اتي
عما قريب واحضنك وكتب ايضا اظن انه قد تم
اخذ قرار اطلاق سراحي بعد المرور بالقليل
من الاجراءات الرسميه ان شاء الله وكان
خان قد اعتقل على يد السلطات السوريه
بتهمه دخول اراضيها دون تاشيره وذلك بعد
عام من وجوده في سوريا لمساعده جرح الحرب
الاهليه الدائره في البلاد وقد تدخل نائب
البريطاني جورج جالوي طالبا من الرئيس
بشار الاسد الافراج عنه ليعود جلوي ويعلن
استجابه دمشق لطلبه وعزمه السفر الجمعه
لاعادته الى لندن كما سافرت والده خان الى
دمشق قبل اشهر من اجل مناشده المسؤولين
الافراج عنه وتمكنت من العمل على نقله من
سجن عسكري الى اخر مدني يمكنها زيارته فيه
وتقول اسره خان ان مظاهر سوء المعامله
كانت باديه عليه واتهم شاه نواز خان
السلطات السوريه صراحه ادام شقيقه دون
محاكمه وذلك لمنعه من التحدث عما شاهده او
حصل
معه هذه المشاهد السعيده ستبقى مجرد
ذكريات اما اسرته فهي محطمه الان وتريد ان
تعلم ما حدث
بالضبط